oh hey what's up wait wait do you mind
if we FaceTime gonna get back on Wi-Fi I
have no data left this mug sorry come on
you've been there it's a great excuse
not to have to talk to mom but maybe not
for long the dream is a constant flow of
data yes sweet sweet unlimited data and
while it went away for a while it's now
back sorta four of the major US carriers
have begun to stretch your data further
than ever before but it's not always
that simple
yes unlimited data plans are back at
least at some carriers at t-mobile and
Sprint
these are the main plans you can get
sign up for one which can start as low
as $60 a month and your phone can use as
much cellular data as it wants there's
one small catch on t-mobile if you hit
more than 28 gigabytes a month and the
network is congested your phone speeds
may drop t-mobile believes an unlimited
data so much that as of January 22nd it
will only offer its t-mobile one
unlimited plans to new customers Sprint
does the same thing at 23 gigabytes
both t-mobile and Sprint say they rarely
have to slam on the brakes
AT&T also offers unlimited data but only
two customers that are Direct TV
subscribers Sprint and t-mobile have
been known as discount carriers without
all the network reliability of a Verizon
or AT&T before considering a switch to
one of their unlimited plans use a tool
like route metrics to see if they have
coverage where you need it but here's
the good news if you stick with AT&T and
Verizon your data now goes further with
no overage options so you have a 10
gigabyte monthly plan now once you hit
that cap AT&T and Verizon won't charge
you a penalty
they'll just reduce your speed to 2g
Verizon calls this safety mode and you
turn it on in your verizon app yes
annoyingly it's not on by default and
only some plans have it
AT&T calls it worryfree data and it's on
by default on
all new plans both AT&T and Verizon let
you roll over data into the next month
so say you only used five gigabytes of
data one month you can use the five
gigabytes left over next month